as Pavan said that I'm going to be
talking about the links between
biodiversity and provision of ecosystem
services and what lies underneath them
and they're going to start by showing
you some biodiversity the world is very
rich in biodiversity we have fantastic
biodiversity but these also produce
ecosystem services that we enjoy and
they're doing so now in fact and I'm not
talking about the provision of air that
we can breathe or temperature conducive
to life I'm talking about this slide is
giving you ecosystem services because
research has shown that merely looking
at an image of the environment reduces
stress and reduces workplace arguments
and things like that so actually you're
receiving a an ecosystem service now and
from this and the underpinning that
ecosystem services are the biodiversity
and sometimes we don't notice that an
ecosystem services provide things that
we don't notice like who has ever
wondered why that we are not very deep
in all the residue from all the species
that have ever existed for 3.7 billion
years ecosystem services have a range of
activities from the top left there and
get this cursor top left there of fossil
stromatolites these are the things that
we believe first created oxygen on the
planet two and a half billion years ago
and the examples are still around today
there are living stromatolite lay up
pads of blue-green algae which produce
oxygen bubbles up from them the picture
in the middle of the green one is other
species of algae producing bubbles of
oxygen you can see there on the top
right the bacteria are a particular
group of bacteria the nitrogen-fixing
bacteria they take nitrogen which
comprises nearly 80% of the atmosphere
but is inert and unavailable to plants
they convert that into nitrate and
ammonium that plants can use and when we
eat plants or we eat the animals that
eat the plants that nitrogen goes into
our system it goes into our DNA goes
into our proteins and amino acids
that's enough of them and that's how we
survive so we wouldn't be here without
things like that provide ecosystem
services provided by effectively
invisible organisms at the bottom there
we've got provisioning services where we
we have timber and we have fish that are
provided directly to us and we use them
in the market but we don't actually look
after our environments that well we
destroy the the ecosystems that provide
the services this is the rain forest
area of Borneo and how its reduced to
the last 60 years and projected to
continue to be reduced by human
activities and it brings into into
debate the sustainability of our
economic model that our existence is
based on our economic existence is based
on we are destroying the things that
keep us wealthy and that's is that was
really the purpose of teeb to try and
bring those things out into the into the
open now this is a paper you might have
recognised from nature in 2009 rocks
drove Mattel from the Stockholm
resilience Institute they did a survey
of the impacts of humanity on planetary
homeostasis
they decided that since the last ice age
the the earth has been fairly equable
for life and we are now putting strain
on that which is putting that
homeostasis in jeopardy and the of the
things that they they recognized and
I'll just mention that this green border
here is what they regard as the safe
limits of these things biodiversity on
the on the left here is is hemorrhaging
from the planet we are losing bird last
year about a thousand times the natural
background rate of loss we as everybody
knows we're as nearly everybody knows
we're pumping carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere at a rate which is making the
the planetary temperature unsustainable
and we're also producing so much
phosphorus and nitrogen nitrogen
particularly but phosphorus is nearly up
to the
that we're fertilizing the broader
environment
we'll use nitrogen and phosphorus to to
add to our crops so that we can grow
more crops and more cheaply but that's
leaking into the broader environment and
causing problems of what they could do
trophic ation overwhelming the natural
systems so I'm going to talk about these
things ecosystem dynamics how
biodiversity leads to functioning in
ecosystems how functioning produces the
services that we benefit in and would
get benefits from and so the lecture is
divided into five sections which are
broadly in line with the chapter two of
the d0 document and I'm going to go
first through these the biodiversity and
ecosystem section so we know from
studies such as Hooper a tower which is
on the reading list that some high
biodiversity increases productivity in
an ecosystem the more space species that
you have within an ecosystem the greater
the production of primary production
that's growth of plants and algae and so
on and secondary production that's
animals that eat the plants so that we
can we can expect greater productivity
and in in line with how many species are
there it also brings greater variation
in species the more species there are
the more chances that that they will
have different characteristics from each
other and that's very important with
something called response diversity when
an ecosystem is put under pressure from
an external driver like an invasive
species population growing or
temperature change or eutrophication
this fertilization of nitrogen
phosphorus the different species
comprising the ecosystem react
differently they handle that in
different ways so that when if some of
them are lost then other species can
continue the function the other thing
that's high biodiversity leads to is
greater chance of having keystone
species keystone species are unusual
species in that they have a very great
effect on the ecosystem
a typical example much cited is the
beaver if you have two ecosystems one of
which has beavers then you're going to
have water lakes dams and
wetlands processes going on in that
ecosystem that you won't have in the one
that without the beaver and so that's a
characteristic of that ecosystem but
from one species which is unusual so it
brings me to the question that should
have asked in the beginning which is
what is biodiversity and the BBC did a
survey amongst them various cities in in
England in Britain when the teeb d0
document was published it was on the
news and they did a survey and they
asked people what they thought
biodiversity was and what if anyone can
guess what the top answer was from the
highly educated British public what
anyone have a guess number of species
not remotely close the top answer was a
washing powder and that really ought to
spell out the level of ignorance for
hair you thought of that because you
knew but in fact it what it tells me is
that it's up to us it's up to people
prepared to study this economists
ecologists academics policymakers is up
to us to solve the problems of
biodiversity and the fact that we depend
on them for so much and we've gotta
somehow convince the great British
public and other publics that it's not a
washing powder
what biodiversity is have tried to put
the gist of it on this side here it is
the diversity of species the number of
species the number of organisms that
they're in one species and the genes
that they have within them and the
genetic variability of that it's the
interactions between species and other
species and between individuals in the
same species and between species and
their abiotic environment that's the
nonliving environment minerals and water
and so on and particularly it's about
the resources they use in the wastes
they produce and how those wastes are
resources for other organisms its flows
at the bottom and I was pondering how to
explain this because I know some people
here are not ecologists by training how
to explain what a what only
ecosystem is and what biodiversity
contributes when I was cleaning out an
area of my backyard which I'd neglected
for a few weeks and I moved the red sack
there and underneath I found a look at
an ecosystem which I wasn't expecting to
see although perhaps I should have done
adjacent to it on the concrete slab
there was nothing but underneath that
there was an area of mud and some worms
and centipedes and wood lice and little
thrashing nematodes and so on if I'd
thought quicker I'd have got my camera
before actually disrupting the ecosystem
but they are some of the components of
it and what I was looking at was the
provision of ecosystem services and the
ecosystem services they provided were
waste removal because the detritus the
leaves and dust particles and so on that
had been blown under the bag and the
combined with the rain running down the
bag had provided the basis for waste
removal that was been gone nutrient
cycling because one of the things that
growing there was a piece of grass
growing out to the side and soil
formation there was quite a quantity of
soil formed under that bag that had been
there for about one month so what I did
was drew a little diagram there's not as
complicated as it seems I'll get that
pointed again if you have a look the the
in blown material that's leaves and bits
of just and so on and the rain combined
with the things that eat it that is
earthworms and wood lice particularly
they eat that stuff and they excrete it
which is a frass and they make a high
surface area and suitable conditions for
colonization of that material by fungi
and bacteria the fungi and bacteria
mineralized the nutrients that means
they take the nutrients that are there
in the tissues of those waste material
and render them available for plants so
they support the growth of the grass was
growing at the side in addition there
was a centipede which is a predator of
earthworms nematodes which are parasites
and all and also they're herbivores as
well so they would have been eaten
the slug and they would also parasitize
the slug and the bacteria they eat and
so on so there are interactions all
these lines are interactions between the
species and they I've got here on the
right the list of what they do the
detritus and water was the was the first
thing that came in the consumption and
excretion that was waste removal
removing that that material that was
coming in in the colonization by fungi
and bacteria and then remineralized
mineralization of the nutrients which is
nutrient cycling another ecosystem
service which which increases fertility
and then support for primary reduction
that was a soil themselves all in one
little space underneath underneath the
sack importantly if the interactions are
lines that are the processes and
functions that are occurring naturally
within an ecosystem that lead to the
provision of ecosystem services the way
these things interact with each other
now if you think of any ecosystem
outside of woodland meadow a pond or
something there will be not a dozen
species there will be hundreds of
species they're all interacting and and
working the minerals and the resources
and wastes and so on that'll give you
some idea of what an ecosystem actually
is very simply okay so if we move on to
a typical ecosystem say a meadow we can
talk about the second aspect of of
biodiversity which is genetic because
within those wild species of plants
there may be relatives of cultivars that
we recognize like wheat and carrot and
so on and any one of those species
contains a variety of genes and
characteristics of every different trait
just as same as we do in the in this
room we have people with brown eyes and
blue eyes and long legs and short legs
some people that are resistant to
particular diseases some people that are
susceptible to them and so on every
characteristic we have genes for it in
grape variety and so do the plants and
when you have say for example this
meadow has a very wet patch
over here or a very dry patch the the
species and the individuals of the same
species that are exist in that perhaps
with different conditions will be the
ones that have the the genes that are
suited to that they'll have tolerance of
wetter conditions or dry conditions or
if there's a agricultural field they
might have resistance to the effects of
invasive species to exotic species and
they will be the ones there that grow in
that point and that's a very good
example of this on chapter 2 Jana you
will have a copy on page 64 of rice
which were in the Indian subcontinent
there were some periods of extensive
flooding and when that went in in
heavily flooded years the rice grew too
long and tipped over and and the crop
was lost to rot
but somebody spotted in in related
species in the wild species of rice that
some of them existed in there in a wet
area that was permanently or wet for
long periods that it didn't have the
same problems so by breeding the genes
of the of the wild species into the
cultivated species the the rise a sativa
that we grow a cultivar was was
developed eventually that had the
tolerance that had the crop from the
yield of the other cultivated rice and
the tolerance to flooding of the wild
species and without the wild species
being present if that they had been
eradicated because of acculturate
expansion also and all your herbicides
then that those genes would not have
been available so that's the lesson in
in why the genetic variation and not
just the number of species is important
for the preservation of ecosystem
functioning and then system services so
the end of section 1
just to recap this is what I want you to
take away from this that an ecosystem is
very complex series of interactions a
network of interactions both among the
species themselves and between the
species and their abiotic their
nonliving environment the more species
they have they're more the higher the
biodiversity
the more the greater range of
interactions that are going to be the
greater range of responses to external
stimuli and pressures so you've got more
chances of the ecosystem persisting in
adverse conditions with the more species
so that's some and that's a greater
range of traits and lastly the other
thing I mentioned at the beginning that
increased biodiversity means increased
productivity
okay so section to ecosystem functions
and functional groups now it's quite
important to recognize that ecosystem
services that we we rely on for the
benefits they give us rely on functions
which are a natural part of the
ecosystem and they are provided by
groups unless you have an individual
keystone species like a beaver I was
mentioning before they rely on groups of
organisms that do the same thing or
roughly the same thing well the same
thing in different ways so for example
at the top that you have water plants
they naturally take up nutrients from
the water column for nitrogen phosphorus
and so on
that helps them grow in doing so they
remove those chemicals from the from the
water column and that means that we have
clean water coming out the end very
important for biodiversity itself for
our aesthetic enjoyment for very
important for water companies have got
to pay to clean water for us to consume
and so on the same with soil microbes
soil microbes as we saw in the in the
example from my backyard they recycle
nutrients and that gives us fertility to
group for other organisms to grow
primary production which is done by
Peter Estoril plants they provide food
for us and for animals arthropods for
example spiders prey on other animals
that's their function so that provides a
service of removing pests so for example
spiders eat a lot of aphids that that
infest wheat and wheat fields can be
protected from the aphids by the spiders
other arthropods like insects for
example by consuming Nature nectar they
pollinate our plants so they're done by
groups of species and importantly when
one species is effect
by an outside force by climate change by
eutrophication by invasive species and
so on some some civvies species may
succumb to it but others won't and so
that provides continuation of the
function and that comes from
biodiversity so functional groups
perform the functions nearly always not
individuals and different species
perform the same function in different
ways so if you take soil microbes for
example some of them will will make
nitrate some of them will make ammonium
and so on they'll they'll contribute to
the to the function in different ways
that's why that the the ecosystem change
need not lead to the loss of ecosystem
service okay this is an example of how
functional groups responded biodiversity
so the blue disc the top there
represents one species in its
environment in its niche and the top
line is a functional group with few
species in it so it's got few species
and it will produce the function but the
functioning will not be to the to the
full potential it'll have reduced
functioning if you take the same
ecosystem in the middle there you have a
larger number of species in the
functional group so greater biodiversity
in that functional group and they
provide the full complement of processes
and to form the function so the
functioning is increased if in a highly
bio diverse system that represented by
the bottom you have far more species the
functioning will then not be increased
further because the full every base will
be covered by the by the middle section
so that the extra species there will not
increase functioning the functional
group is full if you like and so they
are called redundant we call them
redundant species or functionally
redundant species but that actually is a
misnomer because they should be seen as
a sort of insurance so if an
environmental driver comes along to take
out some of the species then
should be enough species the most piece
of the rather most pieces there are to
continue the functioning and as humans
we won't notice the difference in
ecosystem service provision because
there are species there too to replace
those that will be lost or stressed or
reduced function etc having said that a
friend of mine in France Michel cost who
works on microalgae rivers tiny
microscopic plants diatoms he found
three thousand different species of
diatoms which all do the same thing in
rivers in France so I believe it's maybe
some are spare after all and that's
there's there would be more resilient
perhaps the other thing about functional
groups is that some of them are linked
in fact frequently there are what we
call bundles someone's called bundles of
ecosystem services this is where the
same process the same functioning or the
same ecosystem produces a series of
ecosystem services so that for example
the example of use there as an intact
woodland will produce all those and
other ecosystem service it'll produce
pollinators for local crops eat them
it'll produce birds that we enjoy seeing
and they will eat some of the pests from
from crops and so on or from your garden
it'll it'll clean water it'll store
carbon and it'll provide timber and
fiber and animals that we might use or
enjoy looking at so if something happens
to cause an impact on that functioning
of that ecosystem the suite of ecosystem
services the bundle of ecosystem
services are then threatened so we've
got to think about the integrity of the
ecosystem and the health of the
ecosystem in order to maintain because
system services the other links are
trade-offs and this is a very important
concept to understand the provisioning
of one ecosystem service can lead to the
reduced provision of other ecosystem
services this is particularly in managed
systems so if we for example talk about
a farmer who's growing potatoes on a
field or something
he increases the specialization of the
habitat in other words he intensively
manages that land to grow his crop and a
high yield of potatoes he will lose
other ecosystem services and I can show
that by following line a which is the
typical response of ecosystem services
to intensification so if you can imagine
when the area of land is wild it has
high provision of ecosystem services
that's lots of biodiversity lot of plant
species and animal species and when it's
intensively managed there'll be few so
what happens is the farmer comes on and
he clears the land so that first of all
would reduce a lot of the species to
about there perhaps then he will add
fertilizer and that will reduce it again
to perhaps there because a lot of
species most species are evolved for low
nutrient conditions and that's because
there are a lot of species all competing
for the nutrients and the ones that
demand a lot of nutrients get removed
when the farmer comes along and adds
nitrogen and phosphorus fertilizer to
his soil he's doing that because he
wants to promote the growth of species
that respond well to high fertilizers in
this case potatoes so when he does so
the the other species will disappear so
the greater loss then he will add maybe
a herbicide and that will reduce it
further he does that to get rid of weed
species which are competing with his
crop and again a pesticide to remove the
animals that are possibly eating his
crop so by the time he's done that he's
got a very nice high yield of potatoes
but there are no other ecosystem
services being produced now that's a
typical typical response the line a line
B and line C represent management to
maintain the provision of regulating
ecosystem services those on the on the
Left the y-axis to increase the
provision of those whilst maintaining a
decent crop of his potatoes and this can
be done through management for example
if he's an organic farmer he will have
more species he might leave
areas of wild habitat and so and that
will provide the pollinators and the
Predators and so on and if with an
extreme management you can get very high
provision of other ecosystem services
while still maintaining quite a high
yield of course he can't get his very
high yields and have a little ecosystem
services the same time but we'll come
back to that one so this you might
recognize this from the Millennium
ecosystem assessment it's it's where
they categorized ecosystem services into
supporting on the left there supporting
provisioning regulating and cultural
services now the provisioning ecosystem
services are the things that we can sell
in the market their food their timber
and so on the cultural ecosystem
services at the bottom there are things
that we sort of take for granted and we
think they're not very important but in
fact they are the reason that was that
make life worth living actually the
cultural ecosystem services and then
regulating ecosystem services and also
the supporting ones that bring that are
the things that keep the habitat fit for
life fit for providing the provisioning
ecosystem services which are the target
of the farmers activity so without the
regulating and supporting ecosystem
services he can't grow that food so they
are just as important as the
provisioning system services but you
can't sell them in the market so yeah
provisioning services are short-term and
the others are more sort of indirect so
if we go back to this to this graph of
the of the trade offs here you have the
farmer increasing the intensification of
management in order to maximize his
yield but here we have the need to
maintain the regulating ecosystem
services to enable the the farmer to
continue to do that in the future so he
might have to perhaps forego some of the
high yield of his crop where his profits
are and his ability to maintain his
business in order to maintain the
provision
of the regulating ecosystem services so
you can see why the farmer might not be
that keen on maintaining the regulating
ecosystem services he's more interested
in staying in business next year you
can't blame them for that so if they
have to forego some of that they need to
be compensated for it now the
consequences of losing regulating
ecosystem services are complex and
manifold at the top in black and white
we have the 1930s Dust Bowl in the
states where ecosystem services were
ignored entirely and the consequences
were disastrous in the middle that is a
mangrove swamp which is a coastal forest
of particular plants that have these
aerial roots and they can tolerate
flooding in the tidal zone and so on
they are frequently replaced by shrimp
farms and in doing so the local people
who survived from the fish and the
nursery services of that ecosystem the
mangrove and swamp where they the the
fish that they catch out at sea spend
their juvenile stages in those swamps
they are lost and hence this chap
advertising his book let them eat shrimp
because typically it's a it's a outside
corporation which takes the land
converts it to a to shrimp production
some of the local people and managed to
get a job growing shrimps of course but
most of them lose their ecosystem
services that was their subsistence
living and also on there of course we
have ecosystem services loss which leads
to poverty in extreme cases some of that
that's in Darfur in the Horn of Africa
and ecosystem service related and this
is Hurricane Katrina where again
ecosystem services mangrove swamps
particularly would have would have
protected some of the some of the land
around there in the Asian tsunami in
2005 Christmas areas where the weather
mangrove swamp had been reduced were and
removed in favor of things like that
were devastated the villages behind were
devastated when the mangroves
in tact villages were intact that's the
sort of difference it can make to lives
and and the economy okay other examples
are Amazon basin in the in the droughts
the drought caused the deoxygenation of
the water and massive fish kills that
had a profound effects on the local
people in the Arctic of the present time
the the sea ice is is becoming well
there's a debate whether to that this
year will be the lowest area of sea ice
but it has been progressing if you look
at the graph at the top they're
progressively getting lower over the
last few decades and someone's put these
regression lines in which are showing
that the the date of of free ice is
getting closer and closer I think that
hopefully that's a worst-case scenario
that's um when it happens if people will
go up they're getting oil of course and
I just added that because you always get
a picture of a polar bear when you're
talking about the Arctic so I thought
good to go one further and have a baby
polar bear so so enjoy that because it
might as well twang the heartstrings if
you can okay so back to trade-offs in
the in the chapter two and in other
documents such as this European
assessment the answer they're talking
about trade-offs in the in the sense
that managing for one ecosystem service
risks reducing other services such as
biodiversity pollination disease
regulation and so on and that is a fact
that's what happens but it need not
happen if if the environment can be
managed intelligently
so I've got a couple of examples here
you know in a tree plantation in Britain
we've got particularly Wales in Scotland
actually in the northwest timber
plantations whereas a monoculture of
Sitka spruce or monoculture of larch or
something like that made for industrial
reasons and they are cleared clear
felled every 30 or 40 years so while
there's they're there they provide other
services like air conditioning services
they clean water and they protect
against flooding because woodland soils
are very absorbent and like a sponge and
they can protect downstream towns from
flooding
in heavy rain periods so but these are
reversed when the timber is cut every 35
years or whatever it is depending on
species so they provide timber every 30
or 40 years and they provide these other
services after the new trees are about
five years old until they're felled
compare that with a natural woodland
ecosystem and they provide the same
services timber air conditioning clean
water flood protection but they also
provide a lot of other ecosystem
services from food medicines animals
plants carbon storage recreational value
lots of other ecosystem services now can
tree plantations be managed on woodland
sustainable lines or yes they can there
are examples of it some of them in the
states where applet tree a former tree
plantation was managed to remove timber
yearly and other plants were allowed to
grow and what happened was that the the
timber during that cycle of 30 to 40
years of the clear fell the amount of
timber the revenue from the timber was
the same as it had as it had been in the
other city Co system the other
monocultural ecosystem so the timber
revenue was the same but it provided
these services all the time so now that
that woodland is multi trees of multi
age structure and lots of other species
in between okay go ahead okay so and
more so in this in this when you've
clear felled a tree plantation the saw
frequently washes away into local
streams fill them up with silt and all
the nutrients and so on if you're
interested in that there's you have to
look up the story of Hubbard Brook
Experimental Station but they cleared an
entire catchment okay so we move on to
another system the agriculture we talked
about before and regulating ecosystem
services that we that we want to promote
they depend on vegetation but the
agriculture has vegetation so why why
does it remove those ecosystem services
well it does so because of plowing
reduces soil carbon and it reduces the
biodiversity the use of pesticides
reduces biodiversity the the application
of pesticides and fertilizer and so on
compacts the soil and and damages the
soil ecology the fertilizer that they
add being chemical as no organic matter
so that doesn't enhance the soil ecology
either and also they they add indirectly
to to climate change of course and the
fertilizer increases the runoff of
nitrogen and phosphorus and by that I
mean the farmer applies phosphorus and
nitrogen to the ground to fertilize the
crops it rains and quite a proportion of
his expensive fertilizer washes off the
land and runs into the local water body
or adjacent ecosystems and that adds to
the problems of those ecosystems as well
fertilizer also increases the emissions
of methane and nitrous oxide - to
greenhouse gases if you just remember
the other slide I showed you before of
the planetary boundaries where we're
threatening the homeostasis of the
planet these are biodiversity which
you've mentioned here
climate change which are mentioning here
and nitrogen and phosphorus pollution
which we're talking about here so
agriculture adds to all of those things
that we've decided we need to really get
the help or hold on and bring them under
control okay so can the can the
agriculture be managed in sustainable
ways where we can use organic
agriculture with that sometimes leads to
the same problems particularly of
nutrient runoff but the use of the
particular type of plough the keyline
plow which lifts the soil rather than
turns it over use of that increases the
soil carbon because it incorporates
vegetation vegetation better and it also
increases the nutrient availability in
the soil and management specifically -
for water and for nutrients can reduce
the need for applying fertilization
fertilizer and applying irrigation from
the local rivers and so on and additions
of organic matter including creases
biodiversity including those things that
are good for the farmer and things like
new new ideas like an addition of
charcoal crushed charcoal to the soil
adds carbon to the soil it increases
nutrient availability and then store of
nutrients
and it increases water retention which
reduces a need for irrigation and it
does that while increasing yields so
these things can be done it doesn't have
to be quite such a stark contrast in the
trade-offs between between the provision
of the target the potatoes in our case
and the provision of the regulating
ecosystem services you can maintain
these services up here regulating and
supporting ecosystem services by
intelligent farming without reducing the
the total yield of the target crop very
much and there are examples where the
total yield has been increased by
intelligent farming whilst maintaining
those ecosystem services so it's not a
simple trade-off that it first appears
okay that's the end of section 2 so you
need to understand that that groups of
organisms not individual organisms
provide these these functions that lead
to the ecosystem services that we
benefit from increased biodiversity is
in a sort of insurance which leads to
the continued provision of ecosystem
services even when the environment is
under stress intensive management for
one ecosystem service can lead to or
frequently leads to reduction of other
ecosystem services and the consequence
of which are very serious but we can get
round these trade-offs by by intelligent
management of the soil and better
farming practices ok section 3 is a sort
of critical thing to to understand is
about resilience of ecosystems how
ecosystems are resistant to outside
pressures how they respond to outside
pressures and why particularly they may
only curse ystem may suddenly change to
a permanently degraded state and the
pressures on ecosystems from human
activity and human numbers include
climate change introduced species
eutrophication that's this fertilization
of the environment I'm talking about and
they have direct effects on on the
ecosystem
and how it functions so resilient
ecosystems are ecosystems that can
withstand some of those those pressures
and they can either withstand them and
so you don't notice them in the
provision of ecosystem services or if
they are hit they recover quickly so a
resilient ecosystem service is one that
can withstand being buffeted by external
shocks that that continues the existing
service provision and if you remember
from before the increased biodiversity
increases the range of responses and
that's why the existing can have greater
greater resistance and resilience you
know when you have an environmental
driver such as temperature rise and
eutrophication or certain so on there is
a linear response the ecosystem will
respond in a linear way in other words
it's recoverable while the the
environmental driver is not too strong
but if there is a certain point a
threshold point is reached then that
ecosystem can flip to a completely
different state a degraded State and
this graph here is a hysteresis graph
you might have seen it before
it describes the response of an
ecosystem to environmental driver
somebody use the cursor again along the
bottom here we have the increasing
environmental driver which says they
could be populations of invasive species
from exotic places temperature or
eutrophication the ecosystem can exist
in two separate States it can exist up
up here in this state which is the
pristine state or the high quality state
and it can exist down here which is the
degraded State so we have state a and
state B they can existing and this one
is the high-quality state that produces
the ecosystem services that we need and
the the degraded State doesn't so we
have got an interest in keeping the
ecosystem in this particular state here
now if we take nutrients as an example
this is low nutrients in this at this
end increasing nutrients and very
nutrients here and the ecosystem exists
as I say on this line so where there are
low nutrients the ecosystem will be in
its pristine high-quality state
providing ecosystem services for us as
it as the environmental driver increases
the trajectory of the ecosystem will
follow this line until it reaches this
point here this fold and that at that
point the concentrations or the
environmental drive is so strong that it
will suddenly flip to this state here
where it is stable and degraded until it
reaches that point if the environmental
driver is reducing it will progress back
along the line so it will recover and
become more stable if it goes past that
point it will stick a little flip to
this degraded State and crucially if the
environmental driver reduces once it's
in this state it will follow this line
so in other words it will stay in the
degraded State it won't flip up to the
high quality State again that's very
important economically because if an
ecosystem goes moves to the to the
degraded State it can't be repaired
again without a lot of effort and a lot
of expense so yes that thing flashed
there well that's represents is the fact
that between these two vertical red
lines the two folds the ecosystem can be
in either state under the same external
nutrient conditions for environmental
driver so although it's in uniquely
pristine here and uniquely degraded here
between these two vertical lines it can
flip from one to the other and it can do
that when another environmental shock
this disrupts the stabilizing mechanisms
which are inherent in the existence okay
so there's a line which is what we might
expect in response to the increasing
driver as the driver the the new tariff
occation in our example continues why
doesn't the state of ecosystem follow
that straight line so if anyone can
offer an answer to that will be very
impressed expected a the reason it
doesn't is because it is held in these
two states by stabilizing mechanisms
which are feedbacks they are normal
processes inherent to the eco system
which are suited to that state and they
keep it in that state so when it's in
this separate degraded state another set
of stabilizing
mechanisms hold it in that state so
that's why it doesn't follow that
diagonal line they have done the dashed
line and importantly as you move as a
the environmental driver moves along the
distance between the state where the
ecosystem is actually held and the state
where the environmental driver wants it
to be
it grows in intensity so there becomes a
tension in this area and the further
along the environmental driver is the
greater the tension is from where the
ecosystem is and where the environmental
driver is is sending it you're trying to
send it so if something then disrupts
these stabilizing mechanisms then it
will flip suddenly into this degraded
State and the same thing can happen
backwards but the the the chances of it
going are increased as the nutrients are
reduced again so if you're managing lika
system to try to get it back into the
pristine state you need to get your
nutrients or your environmental driver
right back down as low as you can
because you've got a better chance of of
flipping it back okay so the stabilizing
mechanisms are things in the eco system
which are feedbacks which hold it in
that state ok so I'm going to did I just
miss something there
yeah I've explained that the shock
increases so if an external shock so
something coming to remove one component
of the ecosystem that's a key component
if it shocks it it can then move it move
it from either to one state to the other
but it's going to go there anyway if the
driver reaches up this end okay here's
an example of that happening the one I'm
looking at now is
a lake this is looking down into a clear
freshwater lake in the water and you can
see there's quite a lot of different
species of plants there in there there
are a lot of snails and invertebrates
water fleas which the things that eat
the microscopic algae and fish and so on
all living there in multi species that
produces ecosystem services for us so
that dirty water entering this this Lake
will leave clean in fact a lake that I
was working on was in this state and
next to it was another lake that was in
this state this is the microscopic algae
grown to such density that they shade
out the plants and the plants die so
that is a degraded state and that is the
pristine state of the same ecosystem
that's what it can move into dirty water
entering this will come out just as
dirty or dirty is still because of there
be toxins from blue-green algae and so
on the lake that I was mentioning when
when the water like this which is like
pea soup flowed in high quantity into
the clean ecosystem you could see it
evaporating like steam as this highly
dense algae was diluted into the water
and the stability of this ecosystem and
the feedback mechanisms for example the
the zooplankton which eat this stuff
particularly was such that it wasn't
affected by this high input of of algae
and didn't destabilize it and that's
because of the those buffers buffers
that stabilize the ecosystem in one
state so this can this can flip you can
have a switch a shock so something for
example in this instance that might
remove the plants as runoff of
herbicides for example or a lot of boat
traffic which will grind the plants up
can convert it into this state while
we're between those two vertical folds
on that graph I showed you so so between
those that's a sort of thing that can
flip it up returning it to that state
again is very expensive
time consuming and nearly always
ultimately futile it has been done but
under a particular Lake I know in
Norfolk in England they've spent
millions of pounds on one lake and
decades of work trying to restore it to
high condition and failed when they did
when it did return for something where
would it flip back again after a period
of two years so essentially what we're
saying is once they once the state has
gone into the degraded state it's lost
its ecosystem service provision and it's
it can be permanent and that usually is
so you mentioned fire this is a
tributary of the Amazon and the the
picture we normally see from a plane in
the area in the Amazon is like that but
drought because by almost certainly the
climate change is affecting the Amazon
basin quite severely and drought led to
the to the drying out of the rainforest
and fire swept through and that is the
result now we don't know whether there
will be there will be permanent but
typically the wind blows the dust around
the fertility of the soil goes very
quickly in that sort of environment and
recovery if it is possible will take a
long times okay so the end of this one
is undamaged ecosystems are more
resilient they're on that top line of
that Z shaped graph I showed that's
that's more stable and longer than more
species there are and if they're
stressed once they reach a certain point
they can flip if put under stress from
external and if the the driver is
increased to a certain point it will
flip anyway to a degraded state and it
will not go back again if the driver is
reduced there's a very important thing
because some ecosystems produce
high-quality ecosystem services for us
and they won't be they can't be reverted
back to that state if they flip
integrated degraded state without a lot
of effort and money and sometimes not
then okay and importantly of course the
threshold for that regime shift is not
known sometimes we don't know that the
shock the other sharp is occurring but
Queen the two vertical dashed lines is
occurring we don't know it's occurring
there's a lake home that I worked on for
three years that some was subject to
stress from herbicide which it turned
out that the yachting club who didn't
like the weeds tangling their boats had
applied the herbicide to the to the lake
we didn't know that was going to happen
but it then went into the degraded state
and it can't be brought back because as
an agricultural area and you can't you
can't expect farmers to not put
fertilizer on their on their land they
don't want it to run off their land i
that it's expensive but um it does okay
so section four dependency on ecosystem
services of ecosystem services should as
a on biodiversity this in chat in
Chapter two that you've got corresponds
to section three that goes through a
range of ecosystem services and talks
about what they're dependent on where
they derive from the main things you
need from this is the the high quality
provision of ecosystem services is
linked to the ability of the ecosystems
to function normally and the more stress
they are the more subject to human
activities they are the more degrade of
the ecosystem unless it's going to
produce ecosystem services and of course
as we just seen it can flip to a totally
degraded state so a suite of ecosystem
services produce a bundle of ecosystem
services are produced by semi natural
and biodiverse systems and when we have
impacts on them it leads to loss of
services that's what that section 3 says
and you'll be happy that this is a short
section because I've encapsulated all of
those things in sections 4 into this one
table so I'm very pleased because you
weren't going to read it here but that
very please you can get hold of these
slides and you don't need to heed it
leave it here either because I've
highlighted what I want to talk about
these ecosystem services on the left
here the ones listed in that section
depend up upon or derived from wild
relatives wild species ecosystems
forests grassland marine ecosystems
relatives vegetation marine forests wild
habitat biodiversity natural habitat
soil ecology pollinator diversity you
get the picture they are derived from
the wild nature that am drew balford and
Co are talking about in that classic
paper of 2002 economic reasons to
protect wild nature I hope you've read
it's on the list these are the things
that that Andrew Belfort is arguing to
protect and they are the things that
produce the ecosystem services if you
look in the the fourth column the things
that threaten the provision of ecosystem
services are population growth land-use
habitat loss habitat loss pollution
habitat fragmentation land conversion to
other uses chemical agriculture human
expansion you get the picture and the
last the last one is climate change
climate change climate change climate
change it's pervasive it affects the
quality of our ecosystems and that
affects the ability of ecosystems to
provide the ecosystem services that's a
very difficult thing to be able to keep
those ecosystems wild or keep enough
area of land while to provide those
ecosystem services and whilst we're
still maintaining high production of
food and so on and pavn will tell you
that we've in Western society we waste
30 percent of the food that we grow
anyway ok so you'll be pleased to hear
that that's the last bit of that section
section 4 and the lessons you need to
learn from that are that we've got to
learn how to manage our ecosystems so we
don't degrade them because that's how
they they produce the ecosystem services
that we value when we manipulate nature
we'd always degrade nature and that and
these are these are costly so that's it
so section 5 the valuation of ecosystem
services in the in the back of that
chapter
Charles parings wrote the market counts
only the obvious services not the
building blocks that produce them so it
doesn't
count the regulating ecosystem services
and it doesn't count the supporting
ecosystem services or even very much the
aesthetic cultural services obviously
there are tourism industries and so on
which depend on it but mostly it counts
just the provisioning services just
those potatoes that the farmer wants to
produce because that's what we can sell
in the market the rest of it is indirect
but I won't go into these if you read
Andrew Bamford's paper you'll get the
the other things the important thing
also to recognize is resilience thinking
we need to engender resilient thinking
in our policymaking in our economics we
need to think about how to create
resilience in ecosystems and that
usually means reducing our impacts on
them it's important to know that the
value of the ecosystems that we're
losing the ecosystem services rather
that we're losing the supporting
ecosystem services that regulating
ecosystem services are sometimes of
greater value than the target
provisioning ecosystem services that
we're spending our efforts and money on
producing the potatoes themselves might
not be worth as much money as all the
climate regulation the water regulation
in soil formation and so on that the
provision of those destroys there isn't
very important to learn that the
trade-offs that we went through before
it might mean that a farmer must be
compensated for losing his high-end
yield that we showed on that on that
trade-off graph in order to preserve the
provision of the regulating in
supporting ecosystem services so we need
to we need to obviously we can really
encourage and farmers to manage
ecosystems better so that they can get
that regulating as well as the
provisioning system services but if it
means foregoing those it can be
economically worthwhile to do so it's
important to know that economic and
environmental sustainability are the
same thing when you look at the sums and
lastly have put ever them but the market
is a psychopath and I put that because
it has
conscience the market doesn't consider
externalities it considers the price
what you can get the maximization of
yields and so on and I've just put
reference to this book the psychopathy
test because it explains that and it
puts it into context of CEOs and things
like that but it's also a very funny
book cause if you really recommend
reading it's very easy to read so have a
look at that so here we have the the
crux the ecological worldview of child
Krebs of the economic worldview of the
late great Milton Friedman Milton
Friedman said that effectively accompany
the market the same or a CEO doesn't
have to take notice of anything except
the profits for shareholders
Charles Krebs said that that economic
world view of of Milton Friedman will be
superseded this century by an ecological
worldview that is looking at
sustainability looking at the ability to
maintain ecosystems to provide the
services that we need so who is right
the conventional economists will will
point to the fact that developed
economies have better quality
environments than developing economies
there are reasons for that this isn't a
graph of the usual rate of of rising GDP
about three percent a year if you give
or take the odd recession or depression
or downturn or whatever the politicians
call it it usually goes up at three
percent a year and that means that
there'll be more money and and the
politicians will tell you that the more
money there is the more we'll be able to
afford to spend money on cleaning up the
environment and that tells me that they
don't actually get it and this next
addition to this graph shows the costs
of damage from extreme weather which was
rising with climate change between seven
and ten percent a year and if that trend
continued it didn't actually continue it
was a result of things like Katrina and
so on that happened at the same you know
same time if it had continued at that
rate
the total costs of these the damages
from from weather would have equal total
global production by about twenty sixty
five it I don't know whether it will
happen again maybe there'll be another
about a bout of extreme weather damage
but luckily it didn't but it does give
you the message that costs from loss of
regulating ecosystem services through
damage to habitats or through their just
being overwhelmed by the amount of for
example carbon dioxide we're putting
into the atmosphere they can never be
paid for GDP will never increase to the
amount that we can pay to clean up the
environment so it means we've got to
change the way we run the economy and
that's that's where the resistance lies
now this is the lake that I was
mentioning with a clean clear water
state and the other lake that was in the
other picture with flowing into it
that's in Cheshire in the UK little Mir
and I've got that just to show you that
the regulating and supporting eat in
fact ecosystem services that I've got
along the top there of those the first
four that's the pristine ecosystem the
biodiversity within it and the
contingency that species redundancy and
so on the functional groups that lead to
particular functions ecosystem functions
all those have cultural values
educational value spiritual aesthetic
values to us and they also contribute to
the provision of ecosystem service
services which are of material benefit
to humans and we get our benefits from
those ecosystem services directly the
next component is the valuation which is
the subject of this part the valuation
is providing us an economic means to
justify the protection of all these the
first five things the ecosystems
themselves are components of the
existing the biodiversity they're
functioning and the ecosystem services
we've got to justify economically
because we don't regard or the market
which is a psychopath does not regard
all those things you know making life
worthwhile etc as
as worthwhile in economic terms these
last two economic planning by
governments by multinational companies
and so on and legislation government
policy there are the target for the
valuing with a valuation process that's
what we actually want to change now the
first not we already know we know
inherently the value of ecosystems we
know them from our first slide where
where I projected ecosystem services on
to you and the Great's of godlike manner
and that we knew that already and we
know that the the ecosystems are worth
preserving and for their for their
services we just are still working out
the detail for justification of them on
economic terms so that we can present it
to the market economy if governments
wanted to to change economic planning
and introduce legislation to protect
those things they could do so now they
can do it with things like revenue
neutral carbon tax or environmental tax
which which penalizes unsustainable
behavior in rewards sustainable behavior
put this cmf which is an Irish think
tank you can google that which has come
up with this carbon maintenance fee to
do that same system between countries
administered by the UN I believe it's
worth looking at as a principle so
that's what we that's what we're trying
to do we're trying to convince people
the economic means to justifies merely
so that we can convince people to take
it seriously in the economy and that
means we've got to change the economy as
subsequent lectures are gonna focus on
so this is pretty well the last couple
of slides all you need to know about
this is to the right of the line
extensive types of Agriculture have a
far greater energy ratio in other words
they produce more energy than they
consume then it does to the in the more
intensive forms to the left and I just
wanted a show to show you this bit
greenhouse vegetables in winter the
example of this is a German study found
500
75 calories of energy were required to
produce one calorie of food energy if in
greenhouse vegetables in winter and I
found a similar thing probably not quite
as bad as that in my local supermarket
I'm not sure if you get Morrison's here
but Morrison's is a supermarket in in
England and they sell brussel sprouts
which I'm not sure if you know Brussels
sprouts they're like a mini cabbage you
haven't for Christmas dinner and they
start getting scarce about January or
something like that and so what did Mark
Morrison's do they import them from
Australia and they sell them eight or
something in a little sort of scrotum of
eight brussel sprouts for two pound
fifty or two pound seventies which is
like four dollars or something and they
sell those and people buy it that means
in the economic world view that makes
sense but it can only make sense in a
mad world view you can make world view
in an ecological world view that's
insanity to do that because of that
equation there that says probably the
worst case scenario so so to sum up the
last section how am i doing for time
okay biodiversity can be regarded as a
portfolio investment portfolio because
increased biodiversity ensures us
against loss of ecosystem services
because another species will come along
and perform that same function that the
lost one did so that's the first thing
again to repeat that environmental
sustainability and economic
sustainability should be the same thing
they are the same thing if you look at
the figures and work it out and take
care to our natural capital is depleted
this is going to be covered in other in
other lectures anyway but because our
natural capital is depleted all the
things that that keep us comfortable are
our social political economic well-being
are compromised and in fact they are
impermanent because of the depletion of
the natural capital so I'll leave you
with this one this is the g8 leaders a
few years ago planting trees in Japan
and and I think they were persuaded to
buy things like the tea ball though this
I think this is before the team but
hopefully letters are gonna come down
there yes I'm going to leave you with
that okay now where did I get that from
I got that from the idea that Nicholas
Stern that the hard-nosed chief
economist of the World Bank was charged
by Gordon Brown who they're all Tony
Blair maybe to look into the economics
of climate change and he produced a
stern review which you're probably
familiar with and in doing so that
converted him from a disinterested
economist I hope I'm not doing him down
down there to someone who now campaigns
for controlling our emissions of
greenhouse gases and that was because he
looked at the figures he looked at the
sums and that's what you're doing and
that's what we're doing with the with
the team so hence statement and that's
it thank you very much